hey guys it's garyvee with a humongous  announcement the location and dates of  vcon 2023 and to help me is my homie  Gary B hey Gary how are you I was in the  neighborhood and I remembered you asked  me to come by and oh hi intuitive iguana  yo man wow there are a lot of people out  there I mean I knew you had fans but  this Gary B hand me the envelope oh oh  yes of course sorry about that here you  go  wow it is Indianapolis on May 18th to  the 20th 2023 that's right Lucas Oil  Stadium Indianapolis Indiana May 18th to  the 20th over a hundred plus speakers  we're gonna do it bigger and better than  we did in 2022 and I cannot wait to see  all of you and all the V friends in Indy  vcon 2023